nous sommes à présent avec michel
foucher géographe ancien diplomate
essayiste et spécialiste des frontières
michel foucher bonsoir merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur france 24
il s'agit du pire conflit en europe
depuis
1945 ça pourrait déstabiliser tout le
vieux continent c'est pas le pire
conflit un jeu rappelle je rappelle
d'abord la guerre entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan
dès 1988 qui a duré quatre ans un café
plus d'un million de réfugiés d beaucoup
de morts et puis surtout les guerres
yougoslaves
il ya yougoslave et heureusement pour
l'instant on n'en est pas là donc je
crois qu'il faut garder un peu la mesure
via steam un poutine le président russe
a parlé de vouloir des nazifié l'ukraine
il a fait la une référence à la seconde
guerre mondiale ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en ukraine
on est une conséquence
le mot nazi était déjà envoyé dans les
années 30 par staline
j'ai retrouvé ça dans chez les
historiens
pour qualifier ceux qui critiquaient la
politique volontaire de famine ce qu'on
appelle l'holodomor et ensuite en effet
en europe centrale et orientale
la seconde guerre mondiale n'est
beaucoup plus complexe que je dirai à
l'ouest à l'ouest il y avait deux camps
à l'est y en avait trois et les petites
nations
qui voulait se débarrasser de la tutelle
stalinienne ont en effet à un moment ou
un autre coopérer avec avec l'allemagne
nazie
et c'est vrai notamment dans l'ouest
de l'actuelle ukraine donc c'est un
argument si vous voulez que j'ai déjà
entendu quand j'étais ambassadeur dans
les pays baltes déjà en 2004 un
nazi criminels et que c'était un pays
corrompu et c'est donc c'est un argument
siens mais
comment dire il ne faut pas il ne faut
pas sous-estimer le fait que dans le
contentieux
entre
la russie et nous
[Musique]
il ya là il ya l'interprétation de la
seconde guerre mondiale un dans les pays
baltes l'occupation soviétique a été une
libération et une occupation et il ya
partout des musées de l'occupation c'est
la même affaire en ukraine il s'agit pas
de réécrire l'histoire il s'agit d'avoir
une vision de l'histoire un peu plus
complet que complète et elle est
extrêmement complexe dont évidemment c
c'est un argument qui est censé parler
au peuple russe malheureusement la
grande erreur de poutine dans cette
affaire c'est qu'ils sous-estiment
complètement la vigueur du du sentiment
national ukrainien qu'il contribue
d'ailleurs à
consolider et donc les troupes vont
continuer de s'installer les troupes
russes et il va y avoir un phénomène
massif de résistance cette fois ci parce
qu'il ya quelque chose à des formes vous
voyez des pères de familles qui vont
mettre les enfants au vert et qui vont
retourner se battre et c'est ça sera la
prochaine phase de ce conflit on apprend
à l'instant que les troupes russes se
seraient emparés du site de tchernobyl
j'ai une autre question sur les pays
baltes justement vous vous l'évoquez les
pays baltes aujourd'hui sont inquiets
ils ont raison de l'être ils pourraient
être les prochains sur la liste ça c'est
la propagande russe la propagande russe
conseiller j'ai déjà entendu ça en 2004
la propagande russe consiste à créer la
peur chez les pays base avec lui et
personne ne vient pas les défunts et ils
vont dire regardez personne n'est venue
défendre l'ukraine ce sera pareil c'est
pas le sujet tellement le sujet bonjour
c'est l'ukraine et vous venez de parler
de deux d'attac banc ou de prise de
contrôle dans la région de tchernobyl
mais j'ai cartographier aujourd'hui ce
qui se passe pour autant que je le sache
j'ai noté qu'il avait déjà douze villes
qui avaient fait l'objet de
bombardements ou d'attac de forces
spéciales par hélicoptère pas seulement
74 aéroports si vous voulez et on voit
très bien que se dessinent des objectifs
de guerre et à dire toute la côte nord
de la mer noire de dessin à marioupol et
puis enfant tout ce qui est à l'est du
dniepr on peut très bien imaginer un
scénario qui serait ressemblerait
furieusement à celui de la pologne mais
de la pologne en 1795 la parole partagée
et ont trait on imagine très très bien
à une prise de contrôle de toute la côte
de la mer noire et de tout ce qui est à
l'est du dniepr un toute la rive d'olt
juliette la seule la seule hésitation
que j'ai c'est ce qui est ce parce que
c'est quand même extrêmement compliqué à
contrôler mais de toute façon je crois
qu'il s'agit plus s'agit pas d'une
opération militaire spéciale il s'agit
vraiment d'un d'une destruction de
l'état ukrainien en contrôlant la partie
je dirais la plus importante de
l'ukraine la partie utile la partie
industrielle la partie stratégiquement
frontalière de la russie et de la mer
noire et l'idée brut assez on a un
problème ukrainien supprimant l'ukraine
pour supprimer le problème et c'est vers
ce scénario là qu'on va aller loin
d'être halalisation on est la pologne de
1595 c'est le scénario le plus probable
merci c'est raticide c'est absolument
tragique merci beaucoup michel foucher
d'avoir été notre invité ce soir sur
france 24